mr. fee for all its pomp and
circumstance this is not the Victory Day
parade that President Putin was hoping
for not even second time round Russia is
still mid pandemic more than a dozen
cities called off their parades again
because of concerns about kovin
these veterans bust in fresh from two
weeks self-isolation to make sure they
and the president stays safe
but rallying patriotic fervor through
the memory of World War two and the
Soviet Union's colossal loss of life
there is a tried and tested Putin tactic
and he has a vote to win on changing
Russia's Constitution if Gainey's Stupin
who's a deputy for the Moscow City
Parliament once it stopped he's filed a
lawsuit saying it's a crime for people
to go to the polls when covert is not
under control and he thinks this is a
constitutional power grab Anderson was
almost like this khaki t-shirt of course
there may be some other reasons as well
like a desire not to be a lame duck
right but the main reason is his wish to
stay in power as long as he can and this
Constitution will provide it for him
this is Moscow's famous patriarch pons B
place to see and be seen
released early from lockdown Muscovites
her out and partying but some are
worried that it won't last I think there
will be a second wave after the vote
this woman says it seems to me that
everything is leading up to it Yulia
Voronov skaia is a lawyer and one of the
few we meet who's actually read the
amendments one of which is to make sure
that future presidents can't rule for
more than two six-year terms actually
it's not bad because it would be like
you know like you have the your time
like six and then maximum six and then
you cannot be president again except for
this present except for the current
president is they they make this
exception you know it's stability
in the book shops wear masks and gloves
are still mandatory a telltale sign that
this votes a done deal the Parliament
and the Supreme Court have already
approved these constitutional amendments
and in fact they are already out in text
ready to go into force once the people
have had their say the written evidence
that giving this vote to the people is
really little more than a formality
bordering on a fast alia Azhar is a
well-known independent journalist and
local councillor he was one of the
organizers behind last summer's
demonstrations in Moscow but he doesn't
expect there to be more at the moment
people are a little scared scared to be
arrested and also I feel uncomfortable
calling people to go out onto the street
because they could be fine so to be
honest it's difficult to protest that
Amir Putin has watched his approval
rating sink during this pandemic trust
in his leadership at an all-time low
even so the polls predict he'll get his
way on this he may not be so popular but
he's still powerful
dynamic new Sky News Moscow